bueno yo soy periodista así que me gusta
mucho hacer preguntas de forma que voy a
empezar con una existen las razas que
creéis
aquí hemos venido a colaborar esto es
entre dos si si no de todo pues esto es
un poco lo que yo quiero contaros a lo
largo de esta charla
la primera pregunta que tengo para
vosotros es teneis móvil
que levante la mano a la gente que tiene
móvil
estáis esclavizados
y ahora que levante la mano las personas
que tienen whatsapp
pues eso entonces es la verdad
ahora que levante la mano las personas a
las que no les ha llegado esta imagen a
la que se conoce como el negro del
whatsapp
dos tres cuatro cinco personas a las que
no les ha llegado seis siete en fin a la
mayoría se ha llegado a esta imagen
porque porque se hizo viral tanto es así
que incluso nos llegaron felicitaciones
de navidad christmas con un rey baltasar
transformado en el negro del whatsapp
es más incluso hay disfraces del negro
del whatsapp ese señor que lleva un
sombrero tiene un pene sobredimensionado
que le llega prácticamente a los pies y
que como atuendo únicamente lleva una
toalla pues bien para mí el tema del
disfraz del negro el whatsapp deberá
tantísimas personas en los carnavales
vestidas disfrazadas de negro me hizo
pensar que quizá podría hablar de los
disfraces os animo a que saquéis esos
móviles que sé que todos y todas tenéis
para empezar a jugar por ejemplo que
sale cuando ponéis disfraz de negro
yo he escogido lo voy a esperar tengo
solo 18 minutos
yo he escogido un par de los ejemplos
que sale cuando pones negro y uno de
ellos pues redunda un poco en este
estereotipo del pene sobredimensionado y
el otro pues para seguir con los
estereotipos asociados a las personas de
raza negra además por si no fuera
suficiente lleva una lanza pero qué
sucede cuando al estereotipo de raza le
asociamos además el tema del género pues
lo que sucede es esto la primera en
google ponía negra culona mientras que
una lleva una lanza la otra lleva un
plumero
un disfraz los disfraces son inocuos si
no no los vamos a ir avanzando que pasa
cuando ponéis en vuestros móviles en
vuestros buscadores la palabra o las
palabras disfraz de árabe buscad si
queréis
cuando lo buscáis lo que salen entre
otras cosas son estos dos modelos un
hombre cubierto hasta los pies y con una
barba gigantesca que le cubre toda la
cara y una mujer en cambio a la que no
le cubren prácticamente nada
y qué pasa cuando ponemos gitano o
gitana pues exactamente lo mismo un
disfraz una construcción y en el caso de
las mujeres una construcción pero con
menos ropa
sin embargo que creéis que pasa cuando
ponéis disfraz de blanco
efectivamente alguien lo ha dicho que no
hay si ponéis disfraz de blanco y además
incluye los pantallazos de google
aparece un religioso un marinero un
camarero o una camarera no hay un
disfraz de blanco sabéis por qué porque
no existe una construcción con respecto
a las personas de raza blanca porque las
construcciones parten de una parte del
mundo que define cómo es el resto del
mundo y eso evidentemente tiene
consecuencias
hay personas que dirán pero bueno existe
también un disfraz de español un disfraz
egipcio un disfraz de mexicano no es lo
mismo la raza no es una nacionalidad de
hecho hay personas que estemos que
estamos cansadas de que nos digan que si
somos españoles o cómo vamos a ser
españoles si somos negros que a veces
hay una racialización de la nacionalidad
pero en este caso como veis a lo que
alude es sobre todo a veces con un poco
acierto
esa a elementos culturales de un país o
de una nación
las razas no existen es así desde un
punto de vista biológico y este anuncio
lo muestra muy bien todos somos
exactamente iguales por dentro las razas
no existen sí pero cuando salimos a la
calle nos encontramos con realidades
diferentes y no es lo mismo lo que vive
mi madre que es una señora blanca de
segovia que lo que vive mi padre que es
un señor negro de línea ecuatorial
ni siquiera que lo que vivimos sus hijos
sebastián y yo que tenemos experiencias
diferentes por el hecho de estar a mitad
de camino y no ser tan negros de hecho
hace relativamente poco hicieron un
estudio que tenía como escenario a la
estación de autobuses de granada allí
concluyeron que a las personas negras
les paraban hasta 42 veces más para
pedirle los papeles que a las personas
blancas un estudio con la policía
nacional llevado a cabo por la
asociación pro derechos humanos de
andalucía y por la universidad de
granada
así que las razas esa construcción que
se ha hecho socio económica porque al
final si es una construcción social pero
muchas veces para meter dinero en el
bolsillo iniquidades históricas de la
talla de la dudosa talla de hecho como
la esclavitud
si os parece seguimos jugando y seguimos
haciendo preguntas eso somos mi hermano
y yo como ya he dicho no le perdonaría a
mi madre jamás ese babero del vestido
pero bueno eran los 80 y en lo que había
es el caso es que juguemos a de mayor
quería ser
yo yo de mayor quería hacer cuando la
pequeña princesa porque es una cosa rara
ahora se me ha quitado pero de pequeña
yo quería ser princesa y como creen que
eran las princesas
como se imaginan
blancas blancas todas menos pocas juntas
que tuvieron ese detalle ahora sí ahora
y más ahora también estará tal pero hay
una década
tengo anécdotas prácticamente con
respecto a todo yo era buena estudiante
así que casi siempre por sacar buenas
notas era la pelota en las obras de
teatro lo llevaba fatal porque no
funcionó bien de memoria el caso es que
llegó un año en el que toco blancanieves
y mi profesora me dijo que no podía ser
blancanieves que en todo caso negra
carbón pero finalmente de lo que hice
fue de bruja y no de la madrastra para
que se mira al espejo no no nos fue
bruja o sea que no podía hacer
blancanieves no podía ser la princesa
pero sí podía ser la bruja
con el tiempo decidí que mira lo que
princesa no ya lo he visto claro así que
como siempre me ha gustado mucho leer
pues pensé que podría ser escritora pero
como creen que eran las escritoras
venga
voy a luego yo si ponéis en google la
palabra escritora esto es lo que salen
eran mujeres blancas en vista de lo cual
decidí que quizá debía apuntar a otro
tipo de cosas y dije bueno periodista
que eran como
vaya habéis acertado así las cosas
empecé a enterrar mi listón y me
conformé con ser una mujer feliz que
eran
y trabajadora que eran en fin estaba
complicada las cosas me di cuenta que
para hacer
tenía que ser blanca o directamente
asumir que no tenía derecho a soñar
el caso es que ahora soy periodista así
he escrito un librito también pero ha
costado mucho ha costado mucho porque
existe una construcción
mucha culpa de eso la tienen los medios
de comunicación en los cuales trabajo y
que adoro por otro lado pero tiene
muchísima responsabilidad según la cual
las personas negras solo aparecen de una
manera muy determinada muy concreta y
muy desagradable en los medios de
comunicación que es encaramados a una
valla que les desgarra la piel o bien en
unas pateras prácticamente sin cara
difuminados pero cuando se tratan de
mujeres ni siquiera tienen derecho a
tener rostro a menos que estén
embarazadas oa menos que suceda una
desgracia como la que se puede leer allí
y mueren siete mujeres tras bloquear la
guardia civil la patera en la que iban
ahí sí tuvieron cara e incluso un hombre
otra manera convencional es la
hipersexualización ahí tenemos a las
cacao maravillao yo crecí con ellas las
personas que tengan más de cierta edad
que serán unos cuantos sabrán de quién
hablo en los albores de telecinco y de
eso no se libran tampoco los varones de
hecho ya hemos visto el negro de
whatsapp pero aquí podemos leer el mayor
el mayor desfase visto en adán y eva'
una mujer no es completa hasta que un
negro no se la meta
esto en un programa de televisión y
ahondando de nuevo en esos tópicos por
los cuales las personas negras pues
tienen unas propiedades sexuales que en
fin
del viento
por otro lado otra forma común de
representación es la modernidad somos
modernos lo sacan nunca pero cuando lo
sacan es para bueno pues que aparta y
veáis que tenemos de todo fijaos que
modernos somos y oye las hay que somos
modernas pero no todas las personas
negras no son ni es moderno ser negro ni
es moderno mostrar la realidad porque lo
que sucede en la calle es eso diversidad
y basta con ir a colegios públicos
probablemente también aquí pero sobre
todo en las grandes ciudades para darse
cuenta de que las personas ahora mismo
no tienen sólo un color por supuesto en
el deporte ahí si salimos hay que si
medallas que si podéis ahí si tenemos
espacio luego a veces se habla del humor
para justificar determinadas cosas claro
que a ver a quién le hace gracia ahí
tengo el recorte de una revista digital
en la que hablaba de bueno se titula
manual para distinguir a la novia de
mario casas hugo silva y víctor clavijo
mujeres sin nombre porque sólo son
novias de mujeres de y por otro lado se
trataba de una especie de
de antropología del siglo 19 por el cual
nos daban pistas como un pelo más rizado
un labio más grueso o una piel un
poquito más o menos oscura para poder
distinguir a mujeres que claramente no
son iguales esto es bastante interesante
y además animo a que todos y todas
reflexionemos ahora qué es la evolución
de la hucha del domund por la cual he
valija rivalizaban cabezas de personas
del sur del mundo del sur global para
pedir dinero las agitaban este es dinero
para los pobres niños de africano con el
paso del tiempo la cosa fue
evolucionando porque evidentemente eso
ya pues no tenía mucho sentido lanzara
ya los niños a la calle a que pidieran y
empezaron a utilizar a menores con
barrigas hinchadas moscas alrededor para
dar pena y que las personas pudieran
donar esas imágenes se daban por
supuesto
pero estaban vulnerando la posibilidad
de que esos niños pudieran olvidar esto
es más contemporáneo es de 2017 ahí
tenemos a un niño llamado hope desnudo
desnutrido sucio al que una mano blanca
está dando una botellita de agua para
que pueda salvarse no pasa el tiempo o
cumple un año y ya sonríe y está
fenomenal home no va a poder olvidarse
nunca de ese episodio tan terrible de su
vida no van a permitirle que lo olvide
porque está por todo el mundo gracias a
internet
eso es peligroso y además genera que
nosotros vayamos cubriendo de capas de
sedimentos de prejuicios nuestro cerebro
es imposible que no sea así cuando
vosotros vais a áfrica oa algún lugar
del sur y os hacéis una foto con esos
niños a los que rara vez se pide permiso
o por lo menos a los padres como hacemos
cuando estamos aquí la lectura que se
hace en facebook es que solidario
pero si mi padre se va a suiza oa su
veces se hace fotos con niños blancos
pensarán que eres un cuentacuentos o les
denunciaran
todos los niños tienen derecho a que se
proteja su intimidad todos y yo diría
que especialmente en estos momentos de
su vida eso ha generado discurso pues
como que marc y lo dijera en un programa
con mucha audiencia
esto no es como los negritos que vamos a
darles dinero quiero lo mío
o paz padilla me han sorprendido los
negros por ser super trabajadores y
super honestos
por otro lado es común que se utilice la
nacionalidad de las personas cuando es
algo que se estudia en periodismo no es
importante y aparte de nuevo y como
decía anteriormente acaba construyendo
los prejuicios que al final nos
perjudican en el día a día y algo
también bastante común es que nos
pregunten únicamente acerca de racismo
como si no pudiéramos hablar de
absolutamente nada más y créanme yo he
visto got talent por ejemplo este año
puedo hablar de eso y puedo hablar de
otras muchísimas cosas claro somos
personas diversas que tenemos una
opinión esto finalmente tiene
consecuencias y es el vídeo que vamos a
ver a continuación forma parte del
programa que tengo del canal que tengo
en youtube llamado nadie nos ha dado
vela en este entierro en el que
interrogó a personas acerca de la
construcción identitaria de qué
elementos han hecho que ladrillos han
provocado que ahora sean las personas
que son mucha gente en españa es
incompatible la españolidad con la
negritud
para mí no empecé a sentirme africano
cuando me di cuenta de que cuando me
mandaban a mi casa a pesar de haber
nacido en torrejón lo que querían decir
es que me fuera a áfrica conceptos tan
cerrados como patria nación a mi me
limitan personalmente y me limitan
culturalmente e intelectualmente sería
lo deseable que empezábamos a olvidarnos
de banderas porque las banderas son lo
que lo que iba adelante en las guerras
que quisimos dejar atrás no las medias
de comunicación es la
estereotipación están reforzando las
posiciones de dominio de las personas el
yunque europeo que ha asumido algunos de
los estereotipos y a veces me
descubierto a mí misma con ciertos
comportamientos
infravalora tivos hacia hacia otras
personas le llaman negra en el colegio
es como ya tú te das cuenta y dices pero
si soy negro pero y eso es malo no
empiezas a asociarlo con una serie de
cosas creo que voy a estar toda mi vida
buscando un lugar en el mundo en el que
sentir que forma parte de él
y no lo voy a encontrar si eres un
español blanco heterosexual de clase
media o clase alta
que no ha salido de las cuatro paredes
que consideras que son españa en tu
puñetera vida o sólo lo has hecho de
vacaciones la identidad no es importante
seguramente tenemos que organizarnos de
algún modo y decir señores estamos aquí
[Música]
pues yo diría que estamos y que somos de
aquí qué les parece si jugamos a hacer
lo real
[Aplausos]